さーもうすぐ僕の一人旅が始まります
日本からは10時間くらいで着くんで
こっちを夕方に出ると
向こうにはお昼頃に着く予定です
まあ飛行機の中暇なので
のんびりしようと思います
＊くしゃみ＊
はいというわけで
アメリカに着きました
めちゃくちゃ天気良いですね
留学中に泊まる家の方に向かいます
いやーまさか1人でアメリカに渡ることになるとは思ってもなかったですね
緊張します
はいというわけで泊まる場所に来ました
いやー結構イカつい部屋なんですよ実は
結構すごいぜ
はい　こんな感じでございます
うわーイカついイカついイカつい
うおー
すげーすげーすげーこんな感じです
見てこのアメリカ感
完全にアメリカンでしょ
いやーホントに来ちゃったねアメリカ
ちょっと周辺の場所がよくわかってないのでちょっと
近くを散歩してみます
ちなみにここはロサンゼルスだ
女性）what are you doing?
ロサンゼルスのハリウッドに来ております
めっちゃ暑い
うわーめっちゃ人がいますよ
ここがハリウッドなんで映画系の建物がすごい多いですね
ここでこれから暮らすかと思うと
もっと色んな場所を知っとかなきゃなって思います
とりあえずめちゃくちゃ人が多いですね
どうなってんだろこれ
見てこの階段
ここがハリウッドだ～
まあ将来的にハリウッドでなんか
できたらいいなって思います
いやーハリウッドすげーよまじで
ここで今後生活していこうと思います
は？
なんで？なんで？
なんでいるの？
ここハリウッドでしょ？
（悲しげな音楽）
エイジ）ついに見つけましたよ
エイジ）はじめさん！
はじめ）お前・・・
はじめ）ハリウッドまで来たっていうのか？
エイジ）そうです
エイジ）やっぱりはじめさんがいない日本なんていやだ！
はじめ）でも・・・
はじめ）でも俺はもう！
はじめ）ロサンゼルスで3年間勉強するって決めたんだ！
エイジ）それでも僕は
エイジ）今のはじめさんは日本にいるべきだと思います
はじめ）俺は
はじめ）俺は日本には帰らない
エイジ）早く日本に帰りましょう
はじめ）いやだ！
はじめ）俺はこっちでやらなきゃいけないことがあるんだ
エイジ）日本には
エイジ）あなたを待ってる人が沢山いるんだ！
エイジ）それでもいいんですか？
はじめ）俺は...おれはこっちでしたいことがあるんだ
エイジ）アメリカにいたら
エイジ）本場の牛丼食べられませんよ
（悲しい音楽）
帰ろう
～＾ED＾～
皆さん嘘をついてすいませんでした
えーっとロサンゼルスに3年間ではなく
ちょっと盛ってしまいましたね
1週間ほどこちらにいます
ホントにね海外に行く機会があんまりなくて
テンションが上がりすぎて
3年間留学に行きたいっていう僕の気持ちと共にそういう嘘をついてしまいました
心配させた皆さま
申し訳％＆＃’（＆
＊笑い＊
エイジ）反省してるんすか？ｗ
はじめ）してるよｗ
はじめ）ドッキリだからね？ｗ
皆さんに向かった
ちょっとドッキリを
仕掛けたということで
なぜ来たかっていうと
YouTubeの世界的にちょっと大きなイベントがありまして
そちらの方にお誘いいただいて
今回こちらに来ております
はじめ）海外行けなくない？あんまりまじで
エイジ）そーですね
はじめ）滅多にないから
エイジ）普通じゃない
はじめ）普通じゃないですからアメリカに1週間いることが
ちょっとスペシャルな1週間を過ごそうと思っております
はいというわけで
１週間したらちゃんと日本に帰りますので
もう少々お待ちください
日本でめちゃくちゃ溜め撮りしてあるので
僕がイギリスに行ってる間も
日本で撮ってある
エイジ）イギリス行ってないでしょｗ
はじめ）アメリカだーァ！
アメリカにいる間でも
日本で撮った動画が上がると思いますので
いつも通りYouTubeの方をお楽しみください
お休みなさい
切実な終わり・・・痛ッ！待ってやばい